foreign
[Music]
all right
here
yeah I know
[Music]
bro
hey let me
let me do something I don't know if
someone's gonna be there
okay what I need to do
yeah what I need now they need medical
right here
uh let me get paid fucking block you see
in a section real quick yeah
hey we got medical coming up okay
in this medical right hold on
[Music]
over there
so 14.9 so we got more units coming here
to help us with uh traffic
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
we can block a chapter is going to be on
on Tropicana they'll be heading down
Northbound please
[Music]
oh shit
do you know
is there nobody in the car
let me do something I don't know if
someone's going to be there uh I'm gonna
let him know
okay I'm trying to get in the radio
yeah what I need now give me medical
right here okay uh let me get tape
fucking block this thing as section real
quick we'll walk straight
okay
I've gotten over there the block right
here
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hey once you guys backed up I'll put the
tape down
[Music]
once you guys back up I'll drop the
table now I'm gonna cross it because we
got enough units to cover the potatoes
[Music]
so it seems like it happens like do out
there man
marks yeah the skin marks and the debris
yeah like it happened out there and then
maybe jacket
it'll happen over there and it dragged
it out yeah well maybe when they got hit
yeah you lose control you know you get
knocked out and then the car keys
where's he at uh he had to go I have his
car though did he be a bouncer
and then you see he hears a loud bang
and then he comes over here and he's
like apparently
he tried getting in the mouth but all of
a sudden started going crazy you told
the Tomlin yeah they know okay cool yeah
okay
all right
it can be Corvette the motors in the
back okay so when it comes I get like go
to the insurance company for the time
because they'll be stupid
oh because none of the damages happen
yeah so they just fix that in
resell it again
what's that
come on
huh
no so apparently he told me he's going
to be one person and a dog a dog yeah
the dog's gonna be in the rear and
everything's gonna be in the front
that's dude
if you've already been here like maybe
like a couple minutes earlier I'm gonna
be able to get him out no it will be
touched on fire he saw it was fucking
exploding yeah
we're gonna be here all day now
fatal
huh